[Música]
eu gostaria de começar contando uma pt
historinha como todos gostaria de
descobrir minha missão porque vi que
posso deixar de diferente para o mundo
sei que nasci mas se para conter para
proteger para ter certeza de que o que
está dentro de mim vai chegar até você
com todo o cuidado
eu posso ajudar a matar sua sede está em
uma forma bonita
pareço feminina tenho curvas uma roupa
tomara-que-caia cobre toda a minha parte
central contendo informações
quando você olha e imediatamente sabe o
que carrego dentro de mim
despejou um líquido me sinto mais pesada
cheia de conteúdo
começa a minha odisséia até te encontrar
coloco-me numa caixa com outras amigas e
eu sigo dentro de um caminhão escuro
para um lugar grande cheio de casos um
homem muito simpático pega a casa onde
eu estou e me leva para dentro de uma
loja linda iluminada
a kibon vou cumprir minha missão
mas antes e coloca dentro de uma
geladeira
faz frio mas eu gosto a condensação às
vezes cria uma fina pelos em cima de mim
a sensação é boa uma porta da geladeira
o menino lindo de mãos macias e olhos
grandes me pega
imediatamente a tampa e bebe todo o
líquido até a sede daquele menino por 20
segundos fizeram bem feliz agora que sei
para que vem quero fazer de novo
milhares de vezes
muito puder quero trabalhar a temos de
nos últimos dias os que foi isso
me jogaram no lixo aqui está escuro
tem coisas de escolas que serão mal mas
foi um engano
vamos encontrar ainda posso ser útil
ainda posso ser útil
vejam vocês quando eu jogava na natureza
eu posso levar até 800 anos para se
decompor em 20 segundos comprime a
missão levar o resto dos 800 anos
incluindo degradando o meio ambiente
seria garrafa mais triste do mundo
opa peraí
tem algumas pessoas andando aqui no
lixão e elas estão carregando sacos de
lixo ver o que elas estão fazendo estão
pegando algumas latas e algumas amigas
minhas
eis aqui vai me pegar
preciso sair daqui uma mão
finalmente me pegou
coitada dessas pessoas andando aqui
nesse lugar mas ela salvou minha vida